foreign
comes from Thomas in Nevada he says I
hear you talk about pay for your kids
college or higher education why is this
a requirement I'm not trying to pass off
responsibility I went through college
and paid my way through my parents were
capable of helping me pay for college
but they went through college on their
own and said they learned a lot from
budgeting and needing to control their
spending in order to pay for school I
plan on helping them start out with
books and rent but not planning to fund
their higher education decisions is this
a mental change that I need to make or
are there different amounts that I can
help
um
you know this is an interesting
question and it comes up a lot you know
baby step five if you're listening and
you're not sure about the baby steps
maybe step five is there uh to set aside
money for kids college whether it's a
529 an Esa it comes after investing 15
and it comes before paying off your home
so it's important to know where that
sits in this whole equation and you know
Dave we've never said you know we give
some percentages and some guidelines for
some of the other steps but for this one
we don't say and you know you put ten
percent for college or you you do 700 a
month we don't tell you exactly how much
to put because there is a little bit of
a discussion that goes into this right
um and I think that's the first place I
want to start uh you need to be having a
discussion with your kids regardless
whether you plan on having a full fund
set up for them whether you plan on
matching them dollar for a dollar or
whether you're like hey I don't plan on
contributing anything which I will say I
have questions about that
um but the key is you do need to have
those conversations and you need to have
them early because as their parent it is
up to you to help them understand what
that process is it is up to you to make
sure that they're making a good plan a
plan that they can actually follow
through with without debt I don't think
it's a good idea to just leave them out
here flapping in the breeze and hope for
the best and
um I'm kind of going back to my first
thought Dave you know and this is just
coming from Jay talking
I can't imagine not wanting to help them
in some way with college they're my kids
so I might not depending on financial
situations I might not be able to afford
for them to go to Harvard right or
afford for them to go to even the nicest
State School in the area
but I want to help them financially in
some way and I do think that that should
be a goal even if you say okay yeah
we're gonna match your dollar for dollar
I want you working and then we're gonna
put this much in I do think that there
should be a little help there simply
because I mean I'm like I'm your parent
I want to help you out but yeah
paying for college is not a requirement
it's not a requirement he said
requirement and it's not a requirement
it's not a moral thing not an immoral
parent if you don't pay for college I've
often told Single Moms making 25
um that you know we need to teach that
kid how to get um
scholarships yes and how to work and how
to pick a cheap school because they
should just rise up if that's you if
you're a single mom making 25 000 uh
your kid uh you don't have you're not a
bad mom because you didn't pay for their
college absolutely they should just rise
up and call you blessed simply for
feeding their little butts okay so uh
really I mean in that situation that's a
big deal uh now in his case he's able to
pay and then you can start asking the
question so the way I want to ask the
question is this is not what is a
requirement or what is a moral or
ethical it's more back to what you are
saying is okay my job is my moral
requirement is apparent
is to give you uh the tools you need to
succeed in this world that's right brush
your teeth so you have some
that's a good tool to have okay yeah
tell the truth
and you know admitting you lied yeah a
little less punishment but still lots of
punishment because Liars don't Crooks
don't succeed in this world my job is to
grow you into a an adult that will help
you win part of becoming successful as
an adult is to engage in a lifetime of
learning that's right never stop
learning if the last time you read a
book was you're a senior in high school
and you've never done any other training
of any kind since high school you're
probably not succeeding big time oh no
well so and so Dave Thomas started
Wendy's and he was just a high school
graduate yes but Dave Thomas didn't
start and run Wendy's only on a high
school education he was self-taught he
read he learned he grew he was a you
know he was ever he was a lifetime
learner even though he didn't have the
degrees or letters or licenses after his
name but but you know did he build
something the size of Wendy's on the
back of only a high schooler no he did
not
a hundred percent now have I built
Ramsey Solutions based on a four-year
degree and the level of knowledge I got
then absolutely not if I stopped
learning in 1982 when I graduated Ramsey
Ramsay wouldn't be here right absolutely
so a lifetime of learning is your job to
instill in them you're going to be a
reader because leaders are readers
you're going to be engaged in some kind
of learning now then can I
encourage that with some level of help
minimum as you said don't leave them
flapping in the breeze show them how to
do it yes minimum show them how to do it
it is your job to show them how to do it
yeah if you don't want to pay for it
fine but it's your job to show them how
to do it don't expect a 17 year old to
figure this out thank you Dave they
don't have the equipment
okay your job is to go okay here's where
scholarships come from here's where work
comes from teach them to work teach them
to save teach them to budget yeah I'm
for all of that like I've got a friend
that was a professional football player
made bazillion dollars
refused to pay his dad is Blue Collar
refused to pay for his college this guy
refused to pay for a dime of his kids
college
but he showed them exactly how to go do
it in detail
so he upheld that part of it in my case
I showed him exactly how to do it and I
paid for it that's great because I
believe the power of knowledge
not of not of degrees degrees don't have
any power knowledge is the currency yeah
and I believe in that and we paid for
our kids college the other reason we
paid for it is that way we could control
it and help them navigate that process
go to a school you can afford behave
while you're at the school you can
afford and I'm I'm holding a wallet over
the top of your head making you do that
and so you're going to behave or you
we're going to cut this off and they've
got to understand
that debt is not an option because
that's the thing if you if you if you
cut off the money spigot and say it's up
to you it's up to you they've got to
understand the implication of debt
because my coming in my parents told me
all of us all four of us early on you
better be smart or you better be good at
sports because we're not paying yeah and
I'm like okay smart got it got the
scholarship athletic scholarship as well
but I still didn't understand the
implication of debt yep and so I still I
still took out some so no debt pick a
degree that that you can actually make
some money with yeah and go to a school
that's the least expensive and work your
butt off while you're in school I work
40 to 60 hours a week while I was in
college and I didn't die from it I
didn't die from nobody paying for mine
you probably became a better student
because of it Dave yeah not really well
I think because they say part-time is
where you yeah I mean all I did was work
and you know and and but and anyway it
just it wasn't it wasn't healthy but but
uh uh you know I think I had thirty two
hundred dollars in student loans or
something when I came out but that was a
whole different time two issue if I told
you what the tuition was y'all would all
laugh so um but anyway how the heck I
got twenty thirty two hundred dollars
possible but the point is you do not
have a moral imperative to pay for your
kids college
you do have a moral imperative to
highlight the importance of knowledge
and show them how to get it and if you
want to help them get it that's okay too
but save up and pay for it and getting
it is not using debt to get it so really
good discussion Jade really good